bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france manuel mérino
déjà démissionnaire à ce que c'était
l'unique solution pour calmer la rue
calme et les pères vient en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que dans le
contexte que dans lequel est plongé le
pérou l'état est profondément en crise
et nous sommes ce soir dans un pays où
l'état est en fait décapiter le départ
de manuel mérino de la halle de l'anah
en effet est la suite logique d'un
épisode sans fin dans lequel la classe
politique péruvienne est en train de
perdre toute sa légitimité et votre
reportage a très bien montré
avec cet appel à l'idée d'une nouvelle
constitution
il y à véritablement aujourd'hui au
pérou une dérive une dérive dans la
légitimité et dense est dans cet abandon
de représentativité de la classe
politique et on le voit à travers cette
crise au sommet de l'état
alors s'entraîner c'est soeur martine
visca rallye a été destitué pourtant
l'ancien président et il était très
populaire semble-t-il il a été destitué
pour corruption présumée on parle de
coup d'état parlementaire quel est votre
avis il est vrai qu'il ya eu une
interprétation d'un article de la
constitution l'article 37 et que martin
vice carats a été destitué pour entre
guillemets incapacité moral il ya eu une
interprétation par le parlement alors
même en effet que le président vizcarra
était engagé dans une lutte contre la
corruption et les votes ses 105 vote sur
130 qui ont conduit à la destitution du
président giscard a n'a fait que
conclure une dérive depuis 30 ans vous
rendez vous compte au pérou il faut
remonter à 1 8e président dans les
années 80 fernando belaunde président de
1981 à 1985 pour
retrouvez un chef d'état qui ne soit pas
à la suite de son mandat ou pendant son
mandat
plongée dans les affres dans des affres
judiciaires
ces dernières années il faut quand même
rappeler que le pérou à un ancien
président alan garcia qui a été
président de 2006 à 2011 qui a été
poursuivi là aussi pour des affaires de
corruption et qui s'est suicidé alors
qu'il allait être arrêté en avril 2019
d'autres chefs d'état tels que toyota ou
malades 2011 à 2016 pedro kuschynski ont
eux mêmes connu ces problèmes de justice
et donc il faut revenir remonter à 30
années auparavant pour avoir ce
sentiment d'une régularité et d'une
normalité constitutionnelle donc
véritablement les péripéties actuelles
illustrent cette dérive est aujourd'hui
votre reportage est aujourd'hui est un
moment extrêmement important
justement dans la vie politique
péruvienne parce que le pérou attend de
savoir quelle va être la décision du
tribunal constitutionnel quand en fait à
la constitutionnalité du processus qui
avait conduit à la destitution du
président giscard a donc vous voyez bien
les le feuilleton n'est pas terminé
alors le pérou donc qui n'a plus de
président plus de gouvernement aussi on
sait que les législateurs il devait se
réunir à nouveau aujourd'hui pour
justement tenter de sortir le pays de
cette impasse
est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir à votre avis
de trouver une issue à cette crise toute
façon il va falloir en trouver une issue
pour le moment la crise est profonde et
comme je vous dis il faut passer par la
grille des instances nationales
donc le tribunal constitutionnel qui va
devoir qui va rendre un arrêt d'ici
demain sur la constitutionnalité ou pas
sur la régularité ou pas de la
destitution du président martin
biscarrat qui a été
destitué donc le 9 novembre dernier
ouvrant cette parenthèse qui s'est
conclue par la démission de manuel
mérino ensuite il ya naturellement toute
une chaîne qui est prévu par la
constitution et qui conduira on l'avait
vu en bolivie l'année dernière qui
conduira bien évidemment à l'élection de
quelqu'un mais le sujet ce soir et le
sujet actuellement au pérou s'est
naturellement celui de la légitimité de
la représentativité légitimes du peuple
péruvien alors même que le pérou ne
l'oublions pas est quand même entraîné
dans une crise économique dans une crise
sociale importante
à la suite du coc vide 19,1 millions de
cas plus de 35000 décès un pays qui
connaît donc des difficultés désormais
économique et social n'oublions pas que
ce sont presque 80% de la population qui
a des difficultés pour accéder par
exemple à l'eau donc des défis
importants dans un pays qui qui avait
développé des infrastructures notamment
des infrastructures en transport
extrêmement importante mais qui
bénéficiaient aussi d'atouts
archéologique historique d'un potentiel
touristique gigantesque et qui voit tout
ce potentiel à l'arrêt et kaki pour le
siège présidentiel maintenant pour le
reste du mandat intérimaire si je puisse
m'exprimer ainsi et puisqu'il doit
s'achever le 28 juillet 2021
absolument et cette date là aussi n'est
pas une date au hasard le 28 juillet
2021 ça sera évidemment celui de
l'investiture du ou de la nouvelle chef
d'état mais ce sera la date de
célébration des 200 ans d'indépendance
du père ou votre reportage a très bien
montré
il y aura de toute façon quelqu'un qui
sera élu il ça sera quelqu'un a priori
issus du parlement
mais l'autre
possibilité c'est de voir le tribunal
constitutionnel d'ici demain déclaré le
processus qui avait conduit à la
destitution de l'ancien président vise
qu'à la absolument pas légitime et
éventuellement un retour de martin
vizcarra dans ses fonctions merci
beaucoup à vous pascal à drouot pour
avoir répondu à nos questions en direct
sur arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
de l'association lacq francs france
amérique latine